Kick, jump, and punch your way to victory in Kung Fu.
And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game in North America.
I'm Mike. I'm Sean.
I'm Sam. Joe here.
What's up, Joe? You're changing it up.
Yeah. I was expecting to say, and I'm Joe.
Who would have guessed it?
Joe not being here.
Okay. It's Kung Fu time.
I hope everybody, you know, is at least a yellow belt.
There's definitely none of us are black belts just looking around this room.
And take one day when I was a kid, I was a black belt.
You were a black belt?
Yeah. But it was like, I feel like looking back on it, it was pretty BS that they can give a black belt to like a 10 year old or an 11 year old.
It's like, yeah, it's not a real black belt.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah.
Joe, were you being serious?
I was when I was like in high school, but I haven't.
That was a long time ago.
All right. So we'll have to talk about if these skills translate at all into video games.
To the video games.
Specifically the 1985, one of the 17 launch games, Kung Fu Asterisk, as it's sometimes known.
Now, I really tried to do some digging on why it's called Asterisk.
Well, it's not, but like why it's there in the corner.
And the only thing I could really get a concrete answer on was that the asterisk is there because it's made by Irem on the back is like what it says in the asterisk.
So it's like Kung Fu, but made by Irem Studios, not made by Nintendo.
Not to be confused with any other Kung Fu.
Right, right. Don't be confused with Kung Fu.
This is Kung Fu from Irem.
It's not actually the martial art known as Kung Fu.
Right. Now, Irem, we've heard them once before.
Does anybody want to take a guess on what other game they made for the NES that launched with it?
I know.
I know the answer.
Oh, okay. Well, we all know the answer.
Everybody knows the answer.
It's 10-yard fight.
And one one thing I noticed was that the the sound in 10-yard fight.
That's like the only sound you hear of just them.
The feet moving that one is this is in the background of this.
It's so close. Yeah, it's the same.
It sounds the same. Just the cadence is different.
Yeah, different tone, but it's like the same rhythm.
I think. All right. But before we jump into what this game is about, let's do some initial impressions.
Sean, I had a lot of fun with this game.
It was it was hard, but it wasn't hard to me.
in the same way that our previous game was
where it just felt cheap and poorly designed.
This was hard because it was designed to be hard
because it's a really short game
and there are only two different versions of it
which I think are slightly different difficulties.
And I think that it felt good for what it was
and it felt a little like fighting game-y
even though it wasn't really a fighting game.
Sam? Yeah.
First impressions, well,
as someone who read the manual...
Sam, the manual, Smith.
And it had all these different, not combinations,
but it's like if you go, if you jump and then move forward,
then you can do moves in the air and stuff.
I'm like, okay, this is kind of cool.
And it just, it did feel really clunky.
I could appreciate it.
It was like a fun beat-em-up game
and I liked that the moves come out really fast
and really crisp. It was just, it was just really lacking
and there was just this little bit of clunkiness
and a couple things that I think just really prevented it
from being really fun off the bat.
Right. Joe?
So yeah, my initial impression,
I felt like it had a really good rhythm, I guess.
It was very, kind of like Sam said,
the moves came out fast, they were really crisp.
And it was pretty simple.
That was my initial impression
because it does get a little weird later in the game.
But level one's pretty simple.
You know, you're just fighting guys that are coming at you.
Joe, Joe, that's floor one?
Sorry, level one, that was,
that was, what am I thinking?
Did I even play this game?
Floor one was pretty simple.
So my initial impression was pretty positive.
Yeah, and I think that this game,
it oozes a lot of style.
When I first booted it up and said like,
oh, this is a launch game,
it was kind of a little advanced in other areas
that the other NES launch games weren't.
We didn't have a beat-em-up yet.
This was the first of that kind.
And also, just like,
one underappreciated thing
that wasn't in my first impressions,
but just something I kind of noticed along the way,
was you can go forward and backwards,
which is something that even, you know,
soon-to-be-reviewed Super Mario Bros.,
you can't do. You don't get to go backwards in that game.
So it's kind of cool that you have like this
roam through the level.
It's strange that like, you go left.
Yeah, you start going left.
It's a really weird feeling.
But in Japan...
But on the second floor, you go right.
It's like... I'm just saying like, yeah, but...
It's almost like you're zigzagging.
Yeah, you're zigzagging for sure.
Okay, so I'm going to talk a little bit
about the objective of the game
because we mentioned it's a beat-em-up,
but this time has like a little bit of a story to it,
which is kind of fun.
You don't really find out
until like you get through the second floor
that there's a story at all.
Unless you read the manual. In such case, you find out all about Thomas and Sylvia.
Yeah. This is the end of Thomas.
Yeah, you have to save Sylvia from Mr.
X. A very mysterious guy for sure,
but he has a pretty evil laugh.
That's pretty crazy.
This game has voice acting.
Yeah, I liked that.
Yeah. Except...
That reminded me of Final Fantasy VI.
That famous...
That famous weird laugh in there.
Yeah, it did sound...
It definitely sounded like ahead of its time
to have voice acting,
but I think we can kind of break this down
like on a floor-by-floor way.
I think that's like a cool way of talking about the...
Yeah. Talking about the game.
So, let's just go floor one.
If I could start. Yeah.
So, the most common enemy,
and I think it's pretty...
It saturates floor one.
The pink and...
Was it green? I don't know.
It wasn't green. Green is the mini-guys.
Yeah, so... What are we going to call those?
Little people? I think they're called the...
I think mini-guys is good. I call them the snugglers.
Yeah, the snugglers. Because they really just walk up to you
and they just kind of hug you.
And then they'll form like a conga line on you.
And it looks ridiculous.
It does look ridiculous.
Right. They don't attack.
They just... Your health just drains.
I like that they hold their hand up.
As they get close to you,
they hold their hands up
like they're going to karate chop you
and then they hug you.
So, right off the bat,
it's got a really weird feeling to it
because I'm not... Like, I get that they're trying to, like,
wrestle you down.
Like, that's... I think that's what they were trying to get with that.
But it just looks really silly.
This thought never occurred to me
when I was playing the game. Like, it's so true.
It's crazy to think about.
You have to, if you're hearing this right now
and thinking we're making it up,
you have to play the game
because that's exactly what happens.
Three guys will be, like,
pretty much, like, you know,
touching each other,
like, hugging them, hugging you.
Can we make the icon for this episode
of the conga line?
I think we need to. I think so, too.
Yeah, I think that will be the thumbnail.
But what's crazy about that
is then immediately after that,
you're like, oh, that's kind of weird.
That's how enemies behave in this game.
And it's like, no, because there's a guy who's about to throw knives everywhere.
Like, yeah. And that's the first real threat in the game.
Yeah. And they just keep throwing the huggers at you.
And then you get, like, you get a boss.
And I actually, I think I died many times
before I even got to the boss,
which is why I initially felt like.
And then once you finally do get to the boss,
he messes you up.
Oh, yeah, he'll mess you up.
This is the sword guy, right?
That's the sword guy. Right.
And I really like that sword guy.
There was a good feeling of, like,
evenly matched once you kind of, like,
there's kind of like, is he going to duck?
Yeah, it definitely feels like a duel.
He feels as powerful as you.
Yeah, so it feels very, like, one-on-one.
I did think, I don't know,
because you just, your guy doesn't move very fast.
And his moves don't reach very far either.
Yeah, okay, so I think we should talk about that
before we move on too far,
is just, like, talking about, like,
how you fight
before we talk about how, like,
the other people fight. So I think, like, you know,
you do have an impressive amount of moves here.
You've got your, you know,
your punch, your crouch punch,
your kick, your low kick.
You can punch and kick in the air.
So you have a lot of options here.
But I personally found the hitbox
to be a little weird here.
Sometimes if I hit really early,
it would connect. Other times if I hit really late,
you know, like, even though technically I'm seeing,
I'm touching them, it would just kind of, like,
clip through them and they would be able to hug me.
What was everybody else's feeling?
Did you find that once you were being hugged,
you could only get them off you
by ducking and striking?
Like, whenever I tried to punch on standing.
In the manual, it says.
Just a button mash. Yeah, it says a button mash.
But it doesn't use that.
Oh, really? Yeah, it doesn't use that word.
Yeah. Yeah, no, but that's what I was doing too.
I was mashing the buttons.
And I found that that shakes them off pretty fast.
Yeah. They kind of crumple after that.
But going back to your question
about how we felt about the controls,
the hitboxes and reactivity of them,
I found that, like,
they weren't where I would intuit them to be.
Like, my punch didn't have the range
that I thought it did,
and my kick didn't have the range
that I originally thought it did.
But once I punched and kicked a few guys,
then I was able to adapt.
I really, I feel like I didn't,
it didn't matter which one you did.
I don't know if one did more damage
than the other one, or whatever.
I think punch has a lower range.
Punch has a lower range.
Yeah, that was the only difference I noticed
was the distance, but I could tell a punch did the same amount of damage
as a kick. So I would just low kick for most of it,
just because I felt like that.
I thought low kick was just like
a stylish way of doing it.
Like, I really enjoyed the satisfaction of,
I rarely punched.
I was kicking people everywhere.
I tried the jumping moves also,
and I feel like there's no situation
where that is any good.
Well, the thing that was driving me
to play in a certain way,
and it's funny that we would talk about
how we didn't really pay attention to scores,
but in this game, the score is important
because you get a very important one-up
once you hit 50,000.
And if you kill enemies with certain moves,
you get more points.
So if you punch a regular hugger,
you get 200 instead of the 100 you get with the kick,
which I think is an interesting way
to make you balance,
like, am I trying to rack up my score
or am I trying to play safe
with a way that I think is more conservative?
Yeah, and that's a very good point there, Sean,
about, like, you definitely want the one-up,
and, like, that's something where it's like,
you know, we don't think about it anymore, really,
lives in video games,
but in this one, it's short enough
to kind of justify lives, right?
Like, it's not like, you know,
I have to get to world 8-4,
and then it's like, oh, no, if I die here,
I have to start all the way back in 1-1.
It's like, there's only five floors,
but I need these lives to make sure that, like,
by the time I get to floor four
and I'm facing the Black Magician,
it's like, I gotta make sure I have lives
ready to take him down.
Exactly, and getting past all those frickin' moths.
Yes, yes. Okay, so, we're kind of,
we got through floor one,
you defeat the sword guy,
who we all kind of agree is, like,
a good starter villain,
and then you get to floor two,
and things just get, like, mythical,
they get ridiculous, like...
Stuff's falling from the ceiling,
you got eggs that are hatching in front of you,
and then a dragon pops out of the egg,
and it breathes fire at you.
And the fire does a lot of damage.
Yeah. Yeah, you gotta crouch before it gets you,
or you can just try and run by him
before it gets that thing out there.
And the little snake guys, can you do anything?
Do you have to jump over them? You have to jump over them.
Yeah, because I tried low-taking them,
and they just...
They go through my foot.
I want to believe that it was, like,
just a coding error,
but the snake shouldn't,
it should not do that much damage.
Yeah. Yeah, it was, like, half damage.
Yeah. Yeah, the snakes,
really everything on the second floor
kind of was, like, a shock from...
Like, what is this building
where the first floor has regular, like,
regular, I don't know, hugging people,
knife throwers, and people with swords,
and the second floor has snakes, dragons, bombs,
and then, like, tiny ninjas that tumble over you.
So I was very shocked by...
The combination of the three, too,
is also, like, a little ridiculous.
Like, you have the snakes,
the dragons, and these, like, bomb things,
and to avoid one of them
usually winds up with you
getting hit by another one of the other things.
Like, Sean was watching me play very poorly
as I continued to try to, like,
dodge my way out of a snake
only to be hit by one of the pellets of the bomb
or try to jump over the dragon
and then a snake egg hatches
and the snake runs right through me.
And then you'll get past all of that
and then a pot with a snake in it
will just hit your head.
Yeah, and there are those things
that shoot the three little projectiles
and you have to kind of get between them.
Like, those are very difficult to avoid.
And I feel like just coming from the first floor
where you kind of go into it
and you're thinking, like, okay, I got all these guys,
I got people that hug me,
I got people that throw knives at me,
and I got this sword guy.
And then you go to the next level
and it's just, like,
you're just not prepared for it
and then you have to do the whole thing over again.
Like, none of that's there anymore.
Luckily, it's only half of that floor
and then it gets a little bit more standard.
But then you got the boomerang guy
at the end of there. Right, but we also get introduced
to the little people. Can't forget the little guys.
The little people are very strange.
And every once in a while,
one of those little guys will jump and tumble over you
and then they just keep going.
It's like they were just trying to get past you.
They didn't want to fight you.
They just go off the screen.
I never really thought about that.
I guess they, do they have no ill will
towards the player character?
Maybe they're trying to be. Yeah, I think we were just making an assumption.
We were like, oh, there's an enemy and we just kill them
and it turns out they were just walking by.
Maybe they're trying to escape.
And I think one of the people
who are there too.
You kind of look like those other guys.
Yeah. I do think that's funny though.
I noticed that too. Like, if you're crouching,
they'll jump over you.
But I just feel like
they weren't programmed properly.
Like, they probably wanted them
to jump over you
and then surprise you.
But they definitely surprised me
when they jumped over me.
Okay, so yeah,
you get to the boomerang guy
and I think he's a little easier
than the sword guy. I think so.
He could have been the first floor boss.
Yeah, I think that the sword bosses
I still, I think were maybe my favorite boss.
Yeah, because I think
the best, again,
I kind of called it a duel earlier,
but it basically brings
like the name of the game,
Kung Fu, where you're sort of like
feeling out your opponent
more to the forefront.
Whereas, I think when you're
skipping ahead a bit
into like the third floor,
you and you're fighting
that big, like the giant
with like the big punch.
I like to call him
the big man. The big man.
Okay, sorry, giant is that a
derogatory term.
But yeah, you're not really
like sizing each other up.
Obviously, there is an objective
difference in size
and you're really just looking like,
okay, should I punch low
or should I? Right.
And I felt like just a few
quick crouch kicks
killed him pretty easily
compared to the guy
on the first level where you had to really,
it was like, is he going to crouch
when I crouch and then I'm dead?
Yeah. One thing that I was kind of
surprised at
with the first boss anyway
was you go through
and it's like a mad dash
across the first level,
I feel. And then you get to the boss
and you kind of have to wait
and be a little bit more patient
with him,
which I thought in the moment,
I thought, oh, this is kind of cool.
It's kind of like you really do have to
or your enemy,
you consider your opponent
almost like real Kung Fu.
Yeah. But not
because of the asterisk.
Right. But yeah,
I thought that was I thought that was interesting
that it does require you
to kind of be patient,
which is not what I want
to do at the time. But also,
I feel like that's because your character is also
really slow. So.
So you're making your way
to floor three now.
And I know we kind of
talked about the big man
a little bit.
I know his name is actually
pretty similar in the manual.
I don't know if you remember, Sam,
but his name is kind of
similar to that. That's why I was kind of like
I call him the big man.
And then when I look at the manual, I was like,
not that far off.
I'll put in the show notes.
I'll put in the show notes,
whatever he really is. But they also they run faster
in floor three.
Did you notice that? The huggers,
they kind of move
a little faster towards you.
I didn't notice that either. And there's definitely
more of them. They're showing up
more frequently now.
Knife guy, always up to his surprises.
If you crouch, he's throwing down
his feet knives
instead of his hand knives.
Can I, can I mention
one thing that I noticed
at the very beginning of the third level
or the third floor
is,
so there's just suddenly
like a plot. If you didn't read the manual,
which I didn't, the first two floors
are just like, oh, you're fighting people.
And then the third floor just says,
save Sylvia from Mr.
X at the beginning.
And I was like, wait, are there characters
in this game? Who's Sylvia?
Who's Mr. X?
Joe, why can't we just do it?
Thomas is right there.
Sylvia is tied up.
Mr. X is just text.
Yeah, it's a very strange placement.
From the beginning, from the beginning
of level three, I thought Mr.
X was the big man
because he was in the level
that they mentioned Mr.
X. Joe, come on.
So I looked up
the name of the big man.
Okay. It is Giant.
Giant is his name?
I was right. His name is just Giant.
Aw, man, I thought it was
Giant Man or something.
I think he's still Mr.
X. I think that's like a hidden layer of story
that they don't explicitly state.
I think we have to get there,
though, because we'll talk about
Mr. X in a little bit.
He's floor five. If we're going to just move on
real fast to floor four
where all of a sudden
it's like somebody spilled honey
all over the place.
Everybody's dead in this room
because these moths,
I think they're more moths
than bees or wasps,
have just overrun the place
and they are dangerous.
And this is probably
the hardest part of the game for me
because I only got to
our special friend,
the magician.
The black magician.
The black magician once
and I never got to
the next floor after that.
the floor four.
I'm glad you say that. Was the end for me.
Because floor four
was also the end for me
and it was that I didn't know he was called
the black magician. I just called him
the unassuming looking guy
that throws fireballs
and teleports. Not only throws teleports, Joe,
Joe, we're missing a very clear move
that no one else in the game.
I think I know what it is.
You kick his head off
and he just regrows it.
Right. I was so bad.
I was like, is this a puzzle?
Am I supposed to kick his head off
a certain number of times?
I had no idea
how to get past him
and I got to him several times,
never figured out
what the answer was
to getting past this guy.
So I found out that
if you want to know the answer,
this might be a spoiler.
This might be a spoiler
for other people, but it's worth finding out
because it is kind of frustrating.
He kind of goes around
on the Kung Fu boards
as the one punch man
because you have to
crouch punch him
four times
and he's dead. Just four shots
with a crouch punch
and he is gone.
That's it? Yep, that is it.
Why is it called
the one punch man?
I don't know why they call him one punch man,
but I guess it's because
theoretically, if you get close enough,
you could just Yeah.
You know, because you can register
connect your Kung Fu
fan base has some explaining to you.
Yeah, they do have some explaining to do
and they have a lot more
explaining to do later on,
but that gets us
through floor four.
So now we're going
to talk about floor five,
which... Can I say one more thing
about floor four? I just want to see
if anyone else had this experience.
I... Did anyone else
get to the point where this one punch man
apparently turns into
two versions of himself
and surrounds you
and you can only hit one of them?
That sounds like a glitch.
Yeah. Did that happen
to anyone else? Your game is haunted.
Yeah, I thought
it was a glitch because I couldn't
hit the one that was towards the direction
I was trying to progress. I had to go back
and kill the other guy
and he would go away
eventually. And then I could
hit the first guy. That's a concept
in Bloodborne.
Like, did they rip off Kung Fu?
Kung Fu is actually
a Bloodborne prequel.
So, I looked up
the manual. Okay.
Right now. That's cheating.
You're Sam the Manual Smith.
You're supposed to have them in your brain.
I know. Well, here's the thing.
I didn't read the full manual
this time because I got...
It tells you how to
play the game real quick
and I just figured that was all I needed to know.
But then it goes on
to describe every single
enemy and obstacle
that you come across.
And they all have
pretty interesting names.
And... And so I read them
in alphabetical order now?
Like, you're just
going to do that now. No, just some things
I noticed. Like, the first guy,
the first boss, not a sword.
It's a stick. Stick man.
He's fighting with a...
The name is Stick Fighter.
Is it like a... What's that?
Kondo? Is it...
What's... Oh, Kanto?
Yeah, you know what I'm talking about.
Like this... We are so bad.
We're really bad. I'm sorry for anybody
that actually cares. I mean, we don't even know what wedges are in golf.
So, like... And I don't even know
what an end zone is.
If you've been following
since the beginning, you know better.
We're not smart people. I'm sorry.
Okay, so... Sam, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Give me, give me. One more thing. The guys who seem to hug you,
they're called the grippers.
Oh, shoot. Oh, so that was intentional.
So they do just hug you.
Lots of them come to get Thomas.
No specific techniques.
Okay, but this is a localization note.
You know what I mean? Like, this is not
the original intention
of this game.
All right, so let's finally
get to floor five
just to talk about Mr.
X because there's not too much else going on there.
But Mr.
X, when you look at it,
he's like a punk. He's like a skinny,
like, little dude.
Like, he's got like a mullet.
He would be played as the perfect foil for the honorable puns.
by Kiefer Sutherland.
It's so disappointing.
I wish the big man
or giant,
I wish he was the final boss.
I think you've just
confirmed it for me
that the giant is the real Mr.
X pulling the strings.
I feel like if Kung Fu
was a...
that, um,
that would be like the,
you know, the third act
is the reveal
that like,
Mr. X was giant,
but now this new guy
is assuming the role
of Mr. X and now you have
to take him down. Like, you saved Sylvia,
but now you have to stop him
from destroying Tokyo.
All right, and so that's pretty much
the game and then when you
defeat Mr. X,
uh, unfortunately,
you just go back
to floor one,
but now you have like
dragon,
uh, one next to your thing.
So it's like, that's what that dragon
icon is for.
It's like, every time you go
through the five floors,
then, uh,
your dragon number
goes up so you can show
how many times you beat the game
in one continuous play.
Uh, not that worth it,
really. No. Get any more challenging
after you go back around?
Is it like a new game
plus mode on the NES?
There's always the B game
for that. Yeah,
the B game is,
we haven't even, first off, we haven't even talked
about that because I'm pretty sure nobody
made it past the floor
one of the B game.
Yeah, it's a, it's a pretty steep
difficulty curve there.
Just lots of grippers
coming at you.
It's a lot of kicking
for me and I just,
I didn't have it in me.
Uh, but so we were talking,
we were talking about giant,
uh, and how like,
and then we were talking about,
uh, one punch man
who should actually be four punch man.
So, another thing in kung fu lore
is that if you beat the game
to get 50 dragons,
you would be able to play
as Sylvia instead of Thomas.
Is that confirmed?
So, I was genuinely interested,
this is on a game FAQ board,
like this was like in the guy's walkthrough,
he had mentioned this,
so I'm like, that sounds pretty legit,
but this also sounds like
finding Luigi in Super Mario
64. Like,
something that's just not actually possible
and people make up.
Yeah, it reminds me of the,
the Mew truck.
Right, exactly, using strength
and all that stuff. So I looked it up
and I found this one website
where this guy pretty much
made it his goal
to like prove that no,
you don't get to play
as Sylvia
if you beat the game
50 times and he beat the game
like 53 times
and she didn't show up.
So, unfortunately,
you're stuck as Thomas.
Um, black haired Thomas,
not blonde slash brown haired Thomas
from the arcade game.
I don't know why they changed his hair
for the NES version.
Uh, this was a popular
arcade game though.
It was called Kung Fu Master
instead of Kung Fu.
Um, and
so popular in fact
that it found
its way into
the Berlin
International Film Festival.
Wait, what? What?
Is anybody ready for this?
Kung Fu Master
is a film,
a French made film
that was entered
into the Berlin
International Film Festival
in 1988.
So, three years after
the game. It's an adaptation
of the game.
So, it's not an adaptation
of the game. Is it a documentary
of someone playing the game?
It is a woman
who is in her like 40s
who has a daughter.
She is a teacher
at the school and she falls in love
with this 14 year old boy
at the school who goes to the arcade
and plays Kung Fu.
Oh my god.
Okay? What? And,
and it's this whole thing
where it's like this relationship
between them and they actually like
kiss in the movie
and spend time together
and her daughter
is ashamed of her
and the mom realizes
that she can't be like this
and that she used to
date a much older man
so she realizes what this boy
is now going through
and at the end
of the game, not the end of the game,
at the end of the film,
Julian, the little,
the boy, I'm going to call him
a little boy, he's 14
and he's dating this 40 year old woman,
he doesn't know
that she's not going
to see him anymore, I think her name
is Mary Jane and she's decided
that she's just not going to see him anymore
and he goes to the arcade,
finally beats Kung Fu Master,
the game that we're
talking about here, tells somebody
at the arcade, I think he says
to the arcade employee,
call Mary Jane,
tell her I beat Kung Fu
and she doesn't answer
and that's like the end of the movie.
You're blowing my mind
right now. Okay, so I need to
let you guys peek behind the curtain
a bit. Before the recording
of this episode,
Mike said that
there was going to be a surprise
relating to movies.
This was the surprise?
This is the movie. Okay, then you,
we had different surprises
because I learned
while doing a little bit
of research about this game
that the game itself
is based off of
a Kung Fu movie
called Oh my God.
Wheels on Meals.
Wheels on Meals? Not Meals on Wheels.
Wheels on Meals?
It's called Wheels on Meals.
He works in a food truck.
This guy Thomas, and he's got a,
it like takes place
in Barcelona.
like, and he's trying to,
like, Thomas is trying
to save Sylvia in that game.
the names. This is the deepest,
yeah. Please go, Joe.
Please tell us. Can I interject real fast?
So, so,
I think we mentioned at the beginning
of this episode that I'm remote right now,
so I'm not in the room
with them, and I'm at this point
pretty convinced that at some point
they muted their microphones
and said, let's see if we can get Joe
to believe these ridiculous stories
about what movies
are connected to this random
1985 arcade game.
I honestly think
that we have to do
an episode that's just a double feature
where we watch
Wheels on Meals
and Kung Fu Master
back to back
and like, maybe it's a live stream thing.
Yeah. Maybe we'll just watch them
with their own audio commentary tracks
over them. I made this stupid joke
that I'm, I'm gonna just mention
that I made it, but I left it
out of the story. There,
there's a Easter scene
in the Kung Fu Master film
where Mary Jane
is hiding eggs
and then she's surprised
by Julian and I think
that was like
one of the first
video game Easter eggs.
oh wow.
No, you should have kept it out.
This is the most ridiculous
story. We are so off topic
right now. We're on the post show.
Yeah, this is post show.
I really feel like there's so much though,
like, like this is the deepest,
this is a deep cut
of video game. Yeah.
Oh, definitely. But that can only mean
that we are now entering
the essential games list.
All right.
It's the essential games list
and you're playing games
like For Honor
and you're like,
why? I can't,
I can't blame you.
Why are you still
playing For Honor? There's seven million,
seven million concurrent users.
I can play the video game
adaptation of Wheels on Meals.
Yeah, exactly.
Instead of For Honor,
I could be playing Wheels on Meals,
Kung Fu Master
video game adaptation.
And to be honest,
that's probably enough,
right? Like you're probably now
going to pick this game up,
but maybe you want to hear
what we have to say if it makes the essential
games list or not.
The essential games list
is like we vote on it.
We're talking about truly special games
here, folks. Games so far,
only things on it is Duck Hunt,
which was unanimous
and Excitebike,
which I'm pretty sure
some people's stomachs
are turning about the decision still.
So there's only...
Maybe a little regret. There's only two games
in there so far. I still like it.
I'm standing back. Sam still likes it.
I still like it. I still like it,
but I don't know if...
I think I might have
some rethinking of where to put it.
Joe, I think I'm going to
make a super cut of every time you've said,
well, Excitebike.
Well, you know,
I'll send you more
audio files of me
saying that if you want to add more.
That'd be amazing. Joe,
do you want to go first
for the essential games list?
Sure. Kung Fu,
I think it was fun.
I wouldn't shy away from playing it
if you have it around
or if you think
you can find it. You definitely
won't regret it,
but not essential.
You might want to add
one of the movies to your essential movie list,
but as a video game,
I wouldn't. Yeah.
All right, Sam. Here's the thing
about Kung Fu. I feel like
if you're in 1985
and you don't have,
or now, and you don't have access
to anything else,
but you do have this game
that maybe your parents
bought for you and this is kind of
all you have for a little bit,
I think it will get
more fun
if you put a lot
of time into it,
you know? But it's just,
it's frustrating
and it was just not,
it's not on the list
for sure. I was,
I don't know, you just,
you die over and over
and over and over.
Oh, you are going to
ES games. No,
I know, but it's just like,
that's just, that's it.
That's enough of a, I gotcha.
Yeah, I mean, now,
like attention spans
and everything, I don't have the attention span
for this game, I'll say that,
you know? I don't care enough
to get to level five.
Sylvia's not worth it
for me. Sylvia's not worth it.
Hashtag, hashtag sorry Sylvia.
Sam. Sean.
Yeah, yes, okay.
So, I think I like this game
more than the rest of you.
I think that
its difficulty curve
was appropriate
and I know that
there was some jankiness
to it, but it was definitely
a hell of a lot more
responsive than some of our
previous games.
games. I could feel myself
improving on each
successive run.
I really like the
like the ridiculous
plotting and
characters and
enemies and I just,
I always need to
waste at least one
life on
the hug train.
And I don't know,
I really like this game.
I'm gonna throw this for the essential
games. Hey,
wow. All right.
A little unexpected. Yeah.
But, okay,
this is what I'll say
about Kung Fu. You know about the
films. And when you know
about the hugging tree.
and when you know
about the guy's
head falling off
and coming back on
and when you know about the 10 yard
fight steps.
Like when you get deep in this game,
when you really fall
in love with it, it's a good game.
This is a game
worth playing.
But, is it essential?
No, it's not.
And, and there's a couple
reasons, you know, I talked about very
early on in this, the hitbox,
and I don't want to like let that just
fly by. I seriously think
that the hitbox has a huge problem in
this game. And there are
times where I am
like so close to
the enemy and I
do a low kick and
it just doesn't do
any damage. And I'm like,
oh my god,
like he's right. Like I couldn't
even move an inch
closer. I'd be on top of
the guy. I'd probably be
connecting for damage
that way. So I didn't really
like the hitboxes,
wasn't a fan of it.
But this game oozes
style, like even more so
than some of the other games we've
talked about that had style but not
enough to get into
the essential games list. I think this is
actually like a very
complete NES game,
especially as a
launch title. But for me,
there's just not
enough, there's not enough
substance into the
actual gameplay,
despite being able to
do all the different punches and kicks.
There's not enough
there that makes it
worth it to keep,
to keep the grind of
trying to get through
just one round of
five floors, let alone beating the
five floors and saying
like, all right, let's do it again on
Dragon 2. Like, you know,
that's just the
personal opinion. But for me,
not essential. Yeah, I tried
fighting for you guys,
Kung Fu master fans.
And they're definitely out there.
The Kung Fu fan base
stays alive. I still have problems
with you calling it
one punch man,
but I fought for you.
Definitely a four punch dude. Maybe it's because
it's like, it's one succession
of punches. It's like one round
of punches. That's what I was
saying. That's what I was
saying. One group of four
punches. We cannot talk any
longer about this.
So with that,
I'm just going to say
that's all the time
we have for this episode of Nostalgia.
Join us next time
for Pinball.
For more Nostalgia,
please subscribe to our podcast wherever
you listen and be
sure to check out
NostalgiaCast.com.
That's N-E-S-T-A-L-G-I-A
Cast.com.
There you'll find
links to the show and show notes as
well as our other
platforms such as
Twitch, YouTube,
Twitter, and Facebook.
Thank you so much
for your support of Nostalgia.
We thank you for
spending time with us.
I'm Michael Esposito.
You can find me on
at Esposito Film on
Twitter and I'll talk to you soon.
escrito escrito escrito !
Thank you.